えっと まあ今日はこの
タカハシさんのこのチャートがありますからね
まあ別に説明しなくても
それで理解できると思います
で 明確にこういう風に分析して理解すると
僕は考えたのは それだったらアビダルマの試験を受けることもできるんじゃないかなと
で 国でそういう試験があります
資格を取る試験 今は外国といえばシンガポール
マレーシアだけですけどね
試験を受けるのは 他の国はあんまりやってないみたいです
他の仏教の場合もいろんなこのみんなこの証明書というかね
そういうもの好きですから
仏教の知識の場合も何段階かに分けて試験はありますし
また大学のレベルで仏教だけやりたいんだったら
そういう風にまた大学システムが通信系の大学システムが出ているんです
大学の勉強になるとちょっときつくて厳しいんですけどね
まあそれは置いておいて
この前マハンターラマナチッタヴィーティは説明いたしましたね
大初演の いくらかこのパーリ語の言葉を覚えておいた方がいいと思いますけど
マハンターラマナ ヴィーティ
チッタヴィーティというんですけどね
そこでこのマハンターラマナチッタヴィーティと書いているのは
我々の眼耳鼻舌身意ございます
5つございます そちらに色声香味触法
触ですか そういう 5つの物質がぶつかるんですね
物質は1つはこの十七刹那ですか
存在しているんですね
それはほんのわずかな時間なんですね
1秒とか言える時間ではないんです
1 秒間になっちゃうと
刹那っていうのは何億も飛んでっちゃうんですね
で ですからこの刹那っていうのはすごい短い時間単位で
物質は十七刹那間生きているんですね
で その間で我々の眼耳鼻舌身意に触れなくちゃいけない
物質が活動している間で眼耳鼻舌身に触れなくちゃいけない
眼耳鼻舌身というものもまた物質なんですね
目耳鼻のこの感覚っていうのは体の働きですから
それもまた物質で そこは活動している間で物はぶつかっちゃうんですね
そこで起こるこのショックありますね
あるものとあるものがぶつかったら
そこであるショックが生まれるんですね
そのショックはファッサというんですね
コンタクト あるいはこちらではファッサは何でしたっけ？受？じゃない
触 あの触というんですね
で この触はもう本当に物質かどっちかと何かそこら辺考えてないみたいんだけど
アビダルマではそれは心性に入れてるんですね
心の働きだと ですからまあですから
まあそういうふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですね
とにかく目に光がぶつかる
耳に音がぶつかる 味 舌に味がぶつかると
そこで舌が生きていなくちゃいけないし
味自体も生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
それ生きてる間でぶつかるんですね
で ぶつかったらそのショックは
触というんですね で その触から受というウェーダナーが感じることが生まれるんですね
で 触も心であって ウェーダナーも心であって
そういうのは同時に起こっちゃうんですね
で まあそれからものそのものを知るということをでき
出来上がっちゃう 目に光がぶつかったらそのものを知るという働きが後から生まれるんです
すごい厳密に喋ってるんだから
目にぶつかるものはあくまでも光であって
色と書くんですからね
色なんですね それぶつかったら
そこから生まれる感覚がありまして
その感覚を通して認識が生まれるんですね
認識っていうのは その心が自分勝手にする働きなんですね
それで見たんですよという
何を見たんですかというふうに
後からの知識が生まれるんです
ですから 確実に見たものは見えたという保証はないんです
それはどうしてもわからない
本当に私たちは確実にあるものを見ているかどうかはわからないんです
我々に見えるこの部屋であろうが
世界であろうが 全部頭の中で作る認識なんですね
その認識を作るために体に何かぶつかっているんですね
だからそこら辺はもうそれでこのサウタサウトランティカという部派宗教の派閥がありまして
彼らの日本語で教領部と言うんですね
お経と領 領っていうのは領の領なんですけどね
教領部と書いて だから彼らは領として基準として取っているのはお経だけなんですね
他の先生方が言っている全てのものは全部何も関係なく捨てちゃうんです
経典だけに だからテーラワーダ仏教も経典だけじゃないんですね
なんかテーラワーダになっちゃうと
経典も置いておいて 注釈書ばっかり考えたりいじったりする場合もありましたけどね
例えば悪口かどうか分かりませんだけど
ミャンマーのお坊さん書いてるテキストたくさんありますから
読んでみてください もうほとんどお経から引用しないんですね
全部注釈書から こういうふうにおっしゃってますよと言って引用しているのを見ると
もうどこかに注釈書のところなんですね
注釈書の量が膨大かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれはテーラワーダの一つの特色かもしれませんだけど
それもやっぱり自分の国の仏教はまたさらにいろいろいろんなことを考えたりするんだから
それは良くないんだと
かなり前から経典ではなくて
注釈書を大事にすることにはすごい反発が出てきて
どうでもいいんじゃないかと
注釈書っていうのは ブッダゴス大長老までもう残酷に批判したりとかね
何言ってるんですか 間違ってるんじゃないかとか
ああだこうだというぐらいの学者たちも出てきたんだけど
でも間違ってもダンマだったらもう間違っててもブッダゴス長老にも何も言う
ブッダゴス長老の言葉をそのまま経典として考えてるんで
でもブッダゴス長老はただの人間ですからね
かなり変ところとかあることは確かなるんです
でも人間ではもう考えられないほど膨大な知識人であったことは確かなんです
でもその知識も その本人の知識か
彼を支えていた学者たちのお坊さんたちの知識か
それ明確じゃないんですね
彼を厳密に管理していたんですね
スリランカで 自由に奔放れたわけじゃないんです
ですから そのお坊さんたちが自分たちの膨大な知識で
その若いお坊さんをね
コントロールしていたならば
全ての知識はブッダゴス大長老の知識とは言えないし
彼もすごい謙虚な人でしたから
私はただ単にスリランカにある注釈書を編集してパーリ語に翻訳するだけです
それを翻訳して全ての人類に役に立つようなものにしますと
シンハラ語で置いたならば
その国の国民だけの大会になりますからということで
ですから それはそれで置いておいて
このまあこの教養部のという部派仏教の方々が経典だけ基準にする
その点では よりお釈迦様に近いといえば近いんですね
テーラワーダよりも近かったかもしれません
でも その部派はもう消えちゃったんですね
今ないんです で 残っている考え方を比べてみたっても
ほとんど原始仏教の初期仏教にすごい近い
一番近いと言ったっても過言ではないほどの部派でした
彼らもそれなりに自分の意見まだ持ってるんですね
彼らいうのは外界を見られないんだと
認識不可能ですと で テーラワーダの場合は
いえ 外界は認識できますよというふうな立場にいるんです
まあそういう まあそういう差が何の意味もない差
まあ争論かもしれませんだけど
で なぜ教養部がそう言うかというと
この外界から出てくる情報
体に触れて それから生まれる受
感受 感受性ですか その認識するのはその感じたものなんですね
だからそのその人がでも違うものだから勝手なこと感じちゃうでしょうに
確実に私が感じるものは全く同一のものは他の人を感じるということは全くないんですね
それであるならば外界は見られないでしょうと
我々壁というものは見て
あ 見たというのは私が感じたということ
それで他の人 私も見ましたというのは
その人が感じたということで
そうすると感じたことは互いに違うんだから
だから見たという私の認識と見たという他人の認識は同一かないかわからないんですね
それで見た壁はその通りか他の通りかと
また分かったもんじゃないんですね
ですから 本当に私は壁見てますよと言うんだけど
それは他の人にはわからないんです
何見ているかと ということを言ってるんですね
でも教養部いうのは 一応外界に何かエネルギーがあって
物質があってぶつかりますから
まあ外界はあるということはいくらかの推測はできるんだと
でも直感はできませんと
直視することはできませんと
というまあ そういう部派仏教の間にあるこの差っていうのは
そういうすっごいきめ細かいところで
もう互いに違う意見出して
まあ喧嘩していることです
一般の信者さんにとってはもう別にもうどうったことない話かもしれません
じゃあこれでテーラワーダのアビダンマの世界に入っちゃうと
アビダンマっていうのは純粋なテーラワーダ宗派の教えですから
で 初期仏教の教えではないんですね
それは初めから言っていたんだからね
で 眼耳鼻舌身に物質が触れる
物質が十七刹那間生きてると
そこでこの十七刹那が寿命ある物質に我々の目から耳かどっちかでもいいんだけど
触れたらそのこのどれぐらい生まれるんですか？まあ六種類じゃなくてたくさんあるんですね
マハンタ パリッタ アティパリッタという三種類の認識
あのシステムが生まれるし
それでチッタアリーティがマハンタに二つとパリッタには六つで八と
また十四種類が書いてるんですね
で 今日はこのリストをチャートに基づいて簡単に説明終わりたいと思って説明し終わりたいと思ってますから
で この十四種類にどのようになったかというと
例えば見る場合は見られるものが十七刹那間生きています
生きているか 現れているんですね
十七刹那終わったらそれ消えちゃう
消えて新しい物質が現れる
現れたらその新しい物質
また十七刹那間にてまた消える
で 十七刹那間 そのエネルギーが同じエネルギーでいるかというと
そうじゃないんです 生まれる時はもう生まれ
生まれた刹那ではものすごい弱い
それで二番目 三番 四 五
六 七 八になっちゃうとすごい力強い
それからまあ九 十 十一
十二 十三になってまたどんどん力が弱くなる
十七刹那で力が全くなくなって消えちゃう
で 例で言えば あの蛍の光に例えてみてください
蛍が光出しちゃうと あの
まあそれは私はすごい観察してるんだけど
皆様どうかわかりませんだけど
蛍を捕まえてちゃんと見ておかないとそれわからない
その働いは で 軽く光が現れて
ものすごく光って また綺麗に消えると
ピカピカではないんです
この電気みたいに 光が現れてピークになって
また薄くなって消える
また現れてピークになって消える
なんかすごく不思議にこの十七刹那のあれって相当ものすごくなんか綺麗な例えになるんです
あの なんかチカチカと光ったりしちゃうと
いきなり強烈な力で光で現れてパッと消えることになっちゃうんです
そうでもないんです 蛍の光は現れて
上にすごく明るくなって
明かりが低くなって消えると
また生まれて また高くなって消えると
ですから 消える瞬 消えている間と光っている間の比べると光っている間が長いんです
で いじめたらするともう全然光らないようにもする時もありますけどね
で まあ我々も子供の時はよく捕まえて遊んだりしてたんだから
捕まったらもうどうせ向こうは知ってるんですね
そうすると向こうもそれなりにいろいろ意地悪したりするんだけど
もう全く光を出せないとか
まあそれでまあ逃がそうとするんです
逃がそうとすると もうまたまあ光を出し始めたら
それでまた捕まっちゃう
で まあ水分がなんかね
あの薄緑色の光でね 随分綺麗なんですけどね
とにかくこの物質の消滅変化もそういう感じなんですね
まあ蛍の光と同じで この光ってる間
間は長い それで消える
消えてまた光り始めて
光って薄くなって消えると
そういう波で光ってるんです
で まあ物質の消滅変化はだいたいそのような波なんですね
十七刹那間寿命だから
一刹那で現れる 現れてどんどん大きくなって
十六刹那でもうほとんどもう消え始めて
十七刹那できちんと消えちゃう
また一番目の刹那でまた現れていっちゃうわけですね
ということは 物質の一番目の刹那と十七番目の刹那っていうのは生まれる瞬間であって物質はないんです
十七刹那は死ぬ瞬間であって
その時に物質はないんです
だから我々に見られるのはこの間の十五刹那間だけなんですね
蛍の光と同じなんですね
暗闇で見ているんだから
光を出したら見えてきて
光なくなったら見えなくなっちゃう
で ここでこの十四種類がなぜ出たかというと
私たち見る側が目を開けて見た瞬間で
この見られた対象がどんな刹那から見始めたかということなんですね
例えば 見たものの一番目の刹那で私は見始めたら
長い時間見ていられるんですね
十七刹那間  二番目の刹那で見始めたら
十七刹那間が見ていられない
十六刹那間は見ていられる
三番目の刹那で見始めたらまたそうなっちゃう
それで見たものの 例えば十四刹那で私は見始めたら
十四 十五 十六 十七で終わっちゃいますから
三刹那しか見られないんですね
ですから 見たという認識がそういうふうに変化するんだと
見た瞬間において そこで我々にもの見えると仮定したっても
そのものが存在 寿命の年
その見えるものの年によって
見えた認識が変わるんです
生まれたばっかしのものを見ると
それは消えるまで見ていられる
生まれて真ん中の間で見ると半分しか見られない
その時の心の変化 心がどのように変化するかと
で このチッタ・ヴィーティで説明しているんです
このチッタ・ヴィーティは全部この書いているのはこの目だけのことで
それはすべてゲンリービーセッシンにも同じチッタ・ヴィーティなんです
で 一応この大小縁起とか言って
このマハンターラッマナ
マハンターラッマナ・ヴィーティ
マハンタ・アーラマナ
アーラマナっていうのは大小
このテキストでは小縁
小縁と書いてますからね
マハンタっていうのは大きい
大小が大きいっていうことは
大小が生まれてすぐ目に触れたということなんですね
そこでもう一度 このマハンターラッマナ・チッタ・ヴィーティの一と二を見てください
このチャートで そのチャートを見ると
まずアティマ・マハンターラマナもあります
十五にありますけどね
じゃあ一応最初にあの
あの あの 極大小縁起を見てください
その一番目 で そこを見ると
あの 一 第一刹那は過去有分識でしょうし
第二刹那は有分なんですけど
動揺と読むんですか チャラナ
動揺 チャラナと書いてるんですね
この有分身が揺れ始める
弱くなると なぜ有分身が弱くなるかというと
目にこの物質が生まれた瞬間で
生まれた刹那で触れたんだけど
生まれる瞬間では見えません
目には見えるものは その見える対象の第一番目の刹那で生まれた同時に目に触れたと
触れても何見えりゃいいないんだけど
その時は 心は有分状態でいるんです
寝ている状態 でも第二刹那でもうこの物質がもう生きてる状態なんですね
生まれてから生と住と書くんだから住の状態なんですね
で ウッパ―デ・ティティ・バンガとありますから
ウッパーダ ウッパーダっていうのは生まれることですね
それから 2番目のはティティと書くんですね
で ティティっていうのはこの住ですか
ある 生きている間ですね
で 最後はバンダと書くんですね
バンダの漢字は難しいんです
滅ですね それはバンダ
ですから ものにはそういう三段階変えてるんですね
ウッパーダ ティティ バンダ
生 住 滅と 三つも書いておきますね
そこで物質の場合は生は一刹那
滅は一刹那 住は十五刹那
心の場合は生は一刹那
住は一刹那 滅は一刹那
ですが 心の生住滅全部まとめて
また一刹那と呼ぶんです
一番最後の最初の小さな単位は心の刹那なんです
でも 心の刹那も説明しやすくするために
一刹那を生住滅に分けてはいます
分けてますが 本当のところは一刹那
パッと現れて消える それだけ
でもそれでも消えていて
現れていて消えるという三段階で入れた方が理屈は通りますから
そうしているんです ですから
それは心刹那と言うんですね
チッタッカナ 心刹那の場合は生住滅は滅で数えるんですね
普通に刹那というと 心の生住滅の刹那をワン刹那で数えるんです
じゃあ全部この元の説明になり
また戻って戻って説明するようになりましたけど
で 物質の場合は一刹那は生
十五刹那は住 一刹那は滅で
それで生住滅という三段階が成り立つんです
でも時間的には同じではありません
時間的には住の時間は長いんです
ですから 私は蛍の光に例えたんですね
蛍の光を見ると全く同じ
そういう状態なんですね
自然の現象っていうのは大体そういうものなんです
あの いきなり消えて現れて消えて現れる法則は
大体自然現象ではないんです
我々見ているこの激しく点滅しているこの LED とかいろんな光あるんですね
このパチンコ屋さんとか見ると
光がいっぱいもう現れて消えて現れて消えてという循環見えるでしょうし
その時でもこの状態なんです
いくらなんでも自然現象だから
現れる瞬間は短くて 光でいる瞬間は少々長いです
そこでパッと消えるんですね
あれフィラメントで光を出す場合は
フィラメントが赤くなって光出してまた冷めなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 光はゆっくり現れて
現れて光ってゆっくり消えるはずなんです
あまりにも早いんだから
目にはもういきなり消えて現れるように見えるだけ
ですから 自然現象で一般的に見えるものなんです
それも で 自然現象はそうであるということは
その素粒子のレベルでもそのように働くということなんです
で 車を見たっても 車はいきなり最高速度を出せますかね
どんなこのあのレーシング車にしたってもね
このサーキットで走ってる車あるでしょ？道路で全く走れない
急にも八十キロ九十キロからスタートする
そういうものでもまずゼロから始めるでしょうに
止まる時でも 例えばもう二百キロで走っていて
キロで走っていて いきなりパッと止まったと
二百キロは瞬時にゼロになった
全くそうじゃないんです
あのチャコメーターというものは
きちんと二百キロからじわっと下がってゼロになりますから
だから問題はその時間の感覚なんですね
そのレーシング車の場合は
この急にもう百キロ以上出す
車の車輪が回り始めたら
まずいきなりゼロからずっと上がって
もう百まで行っちゃうと
それでいくらかゆっくりまあ二百まで行くかもしれませんだけど
それからブレーキかけちゃうと
二百から瞬時にゼロになる
なるんだけど やっぱり法則は同じなんですね
こちらの法則と 現れる側の車の場合は
スピード出す瞬間は短い
出した瞬間は長い スピードを減らしてゼロになった瞬間は短かったり
それだけ 我々普通の道路に使う車はそこもまた違うんです
その場合はスピード出す時間は長いし
スピードある時間はいくらかあって
減らす時はまた時間かかる
だから急ブレーキなんかは不可能なんですね
ブレーキかけたらもう自分
ブレーキかけた瞬間に持っていたスピードによって
車がどれぐらい走るかの時間はもうまた決まってるんですね
大体まあ百メートルね
もう九百八十キロで走っちゃったら
まあ百メートルぐらいを入れておいた方が安全運転できますからね
ブレーキかけたらまあこれぐらい走りますよと
ですから そういうのはもう自然現象でも見えることで
で この仏教で言ってるこの超自然科学は
決して顕微鏡やら望遠鏡やらそういうものからコンピューターでデータを取って計算して
いろんなからくりをして幻覚を作る必要はないんだと
で コンピューターから
例えばこのなんとか星団見つかったと言ったっても
それは電波顕微 電波望遠鏡で受けた電波を姿にしてするんだよ
実際にそのような星があるかどうか
本当にわかったもんじゃないしね
そういうのはもうほとんど妄想で考えるもので
仏教のものは全然道具使ってないんだからね
自然現象でも見られるそのものが
まあ極端的に真理をたどってみても
それまた同じ法則であるんだという考え方なんですね
ということは 例えば素粒子の法則と全く違う法則で大きなものが動くはずがないんです
車とっても車全部原子でできているならば
原子一個一個持ってる法則で車は動いているんです
で それは別にまあ不思議じゃないと仏教にとっては
で まあそれはそれで置いておいて
物質の流れがそういう風に瞬間で現れて
十五 十五瞬間いて また一瞬間で消える
そこでこの見えるものであるならば
目にこの生まれる瞬間で触れたら
もう心がそれを知らない
生まれた瞬間だから動いてないんだから
ですから第一セツナはうぶんしんにする
第二セツナはどうようしんにする
どうようしんですが それもうぶんしんなんですね
第二でもう式がもう生きている時なんですね
それで第三セツナでもウブン遮断と言うんですね
その時もウブンシンなんです
寝ている心ですけど それで寝ている心は遮断されます
遮断するのは次なんですけど
本当はそれ遮断の前の心なんですね
いわゆるこの第 3 セツナでウブン遮断心ですね
ウブン遮断心というのは実際はウブン心であります
でも次のセツナがもうウブン心ではない
これで遮断されますと
これは最後ですという意味なんです
いわゆる最後のウブン心という意味で
それを区別するために
ただ言葉で遮断心と言うんです
そこでやっと 4番目のセツナで
五蘊陰転という心が生まれるのです
そこでウブン心がなくなって
その代わりに五蘊陰転が生まれる
五蘊陰転というのは心が目覚めた状態なんですね
わずかに目覚めたと どこに目覚めたかというと
情報が入ったんだから
情報がこの眼耳鼻舌身に物質がぶつかっちゃった
ぶつかってショック受けた
そこでこのショックはどこに生まれたかということで
五蘊陰転が五蘊陰転心が生まれるんですね
で 心は寝ているんだから
目に行くべきか 耳に行くべきか
舌に行くべきか 鼻に行くべきか
体のその特定の場所に行くべきかと決めなくちゃいけない
その行く場所を決める心なんですね
五蘊陰転というのは それは 4番目のセツナ
それからもう少々考えてみましょう
で 識が生まれて生まれて
やっと四セツナ年取った時
心が活動始めるんです
遮断心でも活動してないんです
だから過去分心同様心遮断心全部分心だから全然活動していない
ですからアビダンマの哲学的に言うと
ものが生まれて明確に見える場合も
そのものの 4番目のセツナで
いわゆる十七 分の四ぐらい過ぎ去ってから見始めるんです
すごいこれ大事なポイントなんです
で そういうことは皆様アビダルの試験を受けて免許証をもらおうと思ったっても
そういうのは試験で聞けないんです
私が知ってる限りは そういう先生方もそこほどまでは哲学的には知らないんです
ただリスト リスト リスト
リストを覚えているか
覚えてるかどうかね 組み合わせてくるかどうかとかね
それだけのテストですけど
暗記している人とはもう必ず合格すると
私の話を聞くと もしかすると落第するかもしれません
で で 博士論文でも書きたければ
私の話をそのまま書いてしまえば
もう何のことなく軽々と取れるんです
それは向こうにしても大変な発見がいっぱいあると思います
それはそれで じゃあ物が生まれて 十七分の四寿命が取ったところで
我々がそれは知ること始まるんですね
五蘊陰転生まれるんだから
まだ知ったわけじゃない
どこかなと なんか自分の何て言いますか
あれはもう自分の興味というか
気がそこに行くだけのことなんです
そこで五番目の刹那で
やっと五番目の刹那で
それは眼耳鼻舌身の五識の一つ生まれるんです
目で見たならば眼識で
音だったら耳識で まあ耳識でそれなりに識が生まれるんです
味だったらまあ舌識で
もう香りだったら鼻識で
もう体に触れたものだったら身識
どっちか生まれるんですね
そこでこの五識で書いてあるのは
そういう場合 五識の一つ生まれる
それ例えば目で触れたならば
目で触れたものであるならば
五番目の刹那で眼識が生まれるんですね
現れたものがもう例えば十七歳寿命であるというならば
五歳でやっと見えるんです
一歳では見えません  二歳でも見えません
三歳 四歳でも見えません
それをよく覚えておいてください
我々は人間を見るとするならば
もう五歳からは見え始める
それからはそこ以前は見えませんということ
人間の場合でもそれは同じことでしょうに
我々知っている子供は結局十
十一ヶ月でしたっけ 十ヶ月経ってから見え始めるんだから
生まれながらさっぱり見えませんでしょうし
生まれなくても一週間
二週間さっぱりわからないし
いることさえも もうないと等しいでしょうに
一ヶ月間経ってももうないと等しい
それで二ヶ月 三ヶ月になると
何かいろいろ体に混乱が生まれるとかね
食べられなくなるとか
吐いちゃうとかね それで何か体の調子がおかしいとか
また検査するところで妊娠しているとわかるでしょうに
それで四ヶ月 五ヶ月となると
もうお腹が大きくなるは
体はいろいろ変化するは
もう骨の構造がどんどん変わっていくは
それで子供がいるだろうという推測だけ
それは男か女かまだわからないし
やっと手で取って あ 私の子供やって言ってる場合はもう十ヶ月経ってるんですね
歳 だからこちらで言ってる法則が
我々自然現象に見ている法則と全く同じことなんです
真理そのものなんです
ただ 私たちにはちょっとそれはね
冷めた目で無執着の心でそれは観察できないだけ
我々は人間が生まれてから死ぬまで知ってるぞと言ってますけど
それはそうじゃないんですね
人間死ぬ瞬間もまず最初に見えませんし
死んでからもう抜け殻は見えますけど
我々に生きている時は見える
そこで次に見ると まあなんかすどせてないんだと
あ 死んだと どんな瞬間で死んだということも見えません
なぜならば 最後の息を吸う時でも生きているんだから
そばにいても まあそこで話戻りますけど
やっとこの五番目の瞬間で
眼識か耳識か鼻識かなんてか
その五識の一つ生まれるんです
そこで六番目の刹那で
その心がその情報を受け取るんですね
いわゆる五識で起きた変化が受けて領受心が生まれる
だから領受心があくまでも五識によるんです
外とはそれほど関係ないんだけどね
それで何心でしたっけ？サンティーラニチッタ
水道心が生まれる 次に